[Music]
on this friday night the end of an era
comedy legend betty white has died even
a trip to the bank can be exciting if
you wear a ski mask
the touching tributes to the golden girl
the fight to contain omicron it's a
challenge for all of us no matter where
we live record-breaking case counts
reduced isolation rules and the
reluctance for new restrictions
plus going past its peak a promising
covert 19 development in south africa
and the abc's of 2021. zed is for zero
and it's for my favorite story of the
year our mike armstrong has looked back
at the year
[Music]
global national with donna friesen
reporting tonight sonia diol
good evening thanks so much for joining
us this new year's eve we start this
last day of 2021 with a farewell to a
beloved actress and tv pioneer betty
white has passed away today just weeks
shy of her 100th birthday her legendary
career spanned more than eight decades
with loyal fans near and far including
canadian actor ryan reynolds he's
already paid tribute on twitter saying
the world looks different now she was
great at defying expectation she managed
to grow very old and somehow not old
enough
even at the age of 99 betty white never
stopped working ross lord now takes a
look back at her incredible life
i suppose you've all heard the news
betty white held a unique distinction
the longest career of any television
entertainer among her memorable
characters was the sharp tongue suanne
nivens on the mary tyler moore show in
the 1970s gets a little cramped
for a woman with a bosom
you do fine in here
to others she's better known as the
naive rose nyland on the golden girls
the kids had made up this really mean
nickname for me just because i had hairy
legs what'd they call you rose with the
hairy legs
but white's pioneering work came much
earlier she began her tv career fresh
out of high school in 1939.
in the early 50s she made history
at age 28 she was the first woman to
produce a comedy series betty white
in life with elizabeth
will you stop talking like an idiot
please
sometimes i have to talk like an idiot
darling so you'll understand me
she lost the love of her life husband
alan ludden to cancer in 1981 but white
continued to generate laughter
you're playing like betty white out
there that's not what your girlfriend
says
better
better white was also nicknamed the
first lady of game shows she became the
first woman to win a daytime emmy award
for hosting a game show with the ironic
title just men this key just started
this beautiful ford mustang convertible
at age 88 she became the oldest person
to host saturday night live
all along white was a staunch advocate
for animal health working with the los
angeles zoo commission and other
agencies to promote animal welfare but
perhaps her greatest thrill had nothing
to do with tv or acting in 2010 the
american forest service made white an
honorary forest ranger it was a
childhood goal unattainable then because
women were kept out
there
a proud moment in a life full of
resounding achievement
ross lord
global news
on to the latest on covert 19 now and
more provinces across canada are
reducing the number of days a person
who's tested positive would have to
self-isolate those living in alberta and
bc who are fully vaccinated will now
only have to isolate for five days if
their symptoms have cleared up bc also
announcing today that it's fast-tracking
booster shots for pregnant women and
many essential workers and in a new
restriction that's come down starting
from tomorrow visits to long-term care
homes will only be open to essential
visitors
students in alberta are getting an
extended winter break but the province
says it is not going to bring in any
more restrictions heading into the new
year neither is saskatchewan where
students are going back to school next
week as planned as heather eurix west
now explains the prairie provinces
hoping a lighter touch is going to get
them through this omicron wave
with four school-aged kids between the
first and ninth grade brittany swanson
is worried they're behind in their
reading um my son is in grade nine
and he's in behind in math
um
because i cannot teach him grade nine
math the rural alberta family's wi-fi is
spotty at best so online learning is
usually a bust alberta's education
minister says the plan right now is to
have all students return to in-person
learning one week later than originally
planned but
that being said of course we will have
to look at
the the impacts to staff
and also to the classroom despite the
rapid rise of omicron cases in the
province the alberta government has
decided not to impose any new rules even
as the chief medical officer of health
delivered this ominous message heading
into the new year wherever you go and
whatever you do you should anticipate
that one or more people present in any
location will likely be infectious with
omicron even if they don't have symptoms
but alberta is not alone in its
reluctance to introduce more
restrictions we are not imposing any new
public health orders or restrictions or
measures at this time we're continuing
to watch our hospitalizations and our
intensive care numbers very closely and
we may
take further action in the in the days
and weeks ahead with no gathering rules
to date the saskatchewan government has
also decided students will return to
school next week as originally planned a
move this public health expert fears
could be a mistake people will get
infected with omicron and and they would
have no choice but to take themselves
out of work both provinces are
prioritizing boosters and increasing
distribution of rapid antigen tests but
in the face of this rapidly rising
omicron wave we just won't know for a
while how effective that strategy will
be
heather urex west global news calgary
new research from the u.s centers for
disease control says the fisa vaccine
causes mostly mild side effects in
children aged 5 to 11. the data shows
that some children reported pain at the
injection site and then fatigue and
headaches after the second dose the cdc
says it's also received reports of 11
cases of myocarditis or heart
inflammation in the age group
the findings are based on about 8
million doses that have already been
given
and the cdc is warning people not to go
on cruises regardless of their
vaccination status the cdc says more
than 90 cruise ships are currently being
investigated because of covert 19 cases
it is recommending passengers get tested
and isolate for five days after docking
the cruise lines international
association says the majority of
infections are asymptomatic or mild in
nature american cruise lines have not
announced any plans to cancel trips
though some vessels have been denied
entry at some foreign ports
a surge in covert cases have forced the
delay or cancellation of thousands of
flights around the world today more than
2800 flights have been cancelled
globally that includes over 1400 flights
to and from the us and more than 6 700
flights have been delayed airlines are
saying it's because of pilots and crew
who are now in quarantine and that is
resulting in severe shortages in staff
devastating winter wildfires in colorado
coming up tens of thousands of people
forced to flee their homes during the
holidays plus the 10th talks and the
growing divide now between russia and
the us
[Music]
in colorado winter wildfires have
sparked a tragic end to the year tens of
thousands of people have been forced to
flee towering flames that have been
fanned by hurricane force winds more
than 500 homes have been left destroyed
and as jennifer johnson now reports many
say there were only minutes to escape
god help us tens of thousands of
panicked residents were told to get out
of towns northwest of denver
neighborhood after neighborhood
obliterated by wind-driven wildfires a
rare occurrence in colorado this time of
year the scenes were almost apocalyptic
hundreds of houses burned to the ground
this video captured the eerie sounds of
the winds that hit nearly 170 kilometers
per hour driving the flames the length
of football fields in a matter of
seconds it's a pretty profound loss to
lose a house but my wife and i are safe
and uninjured at the moment i'm glad she
didn't take the drive over with me this
morning because it's breaking my heart
i'm sure it would break hers too the
wildfires destroyed more homes than any
other fire in colorado's history
the smoke was so heavy shoppers
evacuating a local costco couldn't see
where to go there's ashes in the sky and
fire in the ground
pretty scary in nearby louisville
colorado a hospital was forced to
evacuate its patients as the fire bore
down investigators say several of the
fires were sparked by downed power lines
this was a disaster
in fast motion many families having
minutes
minutes to get whatever they could their
their pets their kids into the car
and leave
the last 24 hours have been devastating
scientists say climate change is making
wildfires more frequent and destructive
and this region of colorado is extremely
dry the last snow fell december 10th 90
of boulder county is in a severe or
extreme drought which made this heavily
populated area a tender box i would
estimate it's going to be at least 500
homes i would not be surprised if it's a
thousand
the winds are now dying down and snow is
in the forecast both will help
firefighters finally get ahead of the
fires homeowners will eventually return
to what's left of their houses with
little to celebrate as they ring in the
new year
jennifer johnson global news washington
u.s president joe biden and russian
president vladimir putin have exchanged
new warnings over ukraine the leaders
spoke by phone for nearly an hour
yesterday biden says he's made it clear
to putin that there will be a heavy
price to pay with new sanctions if
russia invades ukraine again putin is
warning any new sanctions from
washington could lead to a complete
rupture of relations thursday's call is
the second the two leaders have had this
month and now sets the stage for more
talks between the two countries in
january
ahead south africa and how it's honoring
anti-apartheid hero archbishop desmond
tutu
in south africa hundreds of mourners
have been turning out to pay their
respects to archbishop desmond tutu his
body lying in state in a simple coffin
that's made of pine which he requested
the nobel peace prize winner is being
remembered as a hero who stood against
racial injustice and helped end
apartheid in south africa tutu died on
sunday at the age of 90.
well for the first time since the start
of the pandemic south africa has now
lifted its overnight curfew the
government believes the country has
passed the peak of its fourth wave
that's been driven by omicron which is
encouraging news for countries like
canada still dealing with cases
skyrocketing is redmond shannon
the lifting of south africa's midnight
curfew could hardly come on a better day
for bars and clubs these doors are just
going to be here for display we're not
going to shut these down no more we are
all in all i'm happy and i'm excited
that the curfew has been lifted but i'm
also a little bit nervous because i hope
that people won't abuse that the
government has ended the curfew for the
first time since march 2020 desperate to
help revive its struggling economy it is
the view of the experts
that omicron has reached its peak
and because below that peak
clinical
manifestations
have not led
to a significant change in the hospital
load the more transmissible omicron
variant was first identified in south
africa in november new preliminary
research suggests omicron is leading to
less severe disease experts believe that
is partly down to immunity provided by
vaccines and previous infections
and in england where one out of every 25
people had covered last week a new study
released friday says the risk of
hospitalization is greatly reduced as
low as one third of that for the delta
variant if omicron is less severe it
could transform what the pandemic looks
like another south african study this
week suggests the variant could fully
displace delta
in my opinion
this outcome might show that it may
disrupt our lives less
than it did before but the world health
organization is warning despite early
research findings global case numbers
are at unprecedented levels we don't
want people to become pleasant saying
this is not severe this is mild and we
have to be very careful in that
narrative almost 2 million new cases
were recorded worldwide on thursday
redmond shannon global news london
well from a to zed coming up next we
recap 2021 one letter at a time
well as we wrap up the last few hours of
2021 we're going to take a moment to
look back at this past year once again
the pandemic has dominated our lives but
so many other events have happened some
inspired us some shocked us and several
made us cry it is time for an annual
global national tradition now as our
mike armstrong looks back at the year
that was from a to z
clean release ignition let us begin with
space good rocket motor burn barely
a is for arc the shape like up and down
which is basically all billionaires
bezos and branson did with their space
launches this year i wanted to be
impressed but we've kind of been doing
that for 60 years i saw darkness i
thought i was going to see the world but
we were quite high enough
sticking with that theme b is for
billionaires worldwide the pandemic has
pushed about 100 million people into
poverty while the world's richest
relative handful of people are worth
trillions more
which brings us to mark zuckerberg i'm
here today because i believe facebook's
products harm children c is for
compulsion we started the year knowing
social media could be addictive for some
in 2021 it was confirmed facebook knows
it's intentional i don't think it'll be
reached for a very long time if ever but
d is for decorated penny oleksiak won
three more medals at the tokyo games and
is now the most decorated canadian
olympian of all time seven and counting
stuck in the suez and going nowhere e is
forever given the ship that got stuck
sideways in the suez canal a story that
reminded me of my family's houseboat
vacation a few years back very relatable
you know sometimes
f is for feud two of golf's biggest
players really don't like each other i
don't think we've ever gotten along they
tried to iron things out with a match in
november it didn't work enough said wait
did we just become best friends
g is for gamestop 2021 had meme stocks
crypto and nfts even if this goes to
zero and i lose everything i like being
a part of it
h is for haiti an assassination a gang
crisis a hostage-taking crisis
it just doesn't seem to end
i is for insurrection a word some have
used to describe what was a surreal day
in the u.s
j is for juvenile we did have our own
embarrassing election moment when a
protester threw rocks at the prime
minister
[Applause]
now k
has to be for kamloops bc the remains of
215 children were found in unmarked
graves on the grounds of the so-called
kamloops indian residential school but
schools aren't supposed to have
cemeteries
these were something else
the war was against our children it's a
crime scene
we've got to leave town
l is fort litton go the bc village
almost erased from the map this summer
by fire
literally in minutes
everything i had was in there
m is for nazar muhammad
nothing in afghanistan this year went
the way it should have but one story
that stuck with me was early on as the
taliban swept back into power the
political killing of a comedian
one with an incredible lack
n is for the north which is where
canada's new governor general comes from
if you missed mary simon swearing in try
to find it it's worth the time
[Music]
community transmission has been
established
o is for omicron covert 19 had to be on
this list somewhere right now this spot
feels appropriate like everything else
we'll get through it we go through wave
one two and three we'll get through wave
four one on three but a lot of that's
drilled by luke pro cop p is for pro cop
in july predator's prospect luke prokop
came out as gay the first player under
contract with an nhl team to do so i'm
accepting who i am and how did the
hockey world react well exactly as you
would hope it would what he decided to
do was so good on so many levels it was
decided that the group would not alert
human resources or cue is for questions
specifically what were they thinking the
chicago blackhawks sexual abuse cover-up
seems inexplicable brad aldridge
we the jury in the above entitled matter
as to r is for reckoning in the case of
derek chovin find the defendant guilty
the former police officer responsible
for the death of george floyd was
sentenced to 22 and a half years in
prison we're adjourned
[Music]
s is for sumas lake re-flooded another
reminder of the power of water as if we
needed it
it's good to be out here and just
playing again t is for tiger woods doing
twice the posted speed limit in february
he almost died one of the greatest
athletes of all time but not known for
great judgment
u is for upset my beloved canadians had
a few in the playoffs this was my
favorite and they'll punch their ticket
to winnipeg it's wonderful v is for
visit a lot of people saw loved ones for
the first time in a long time this year
w is for wow
the squid game was one of those things
you didn't see coming
now x is the roman numeral for ten so
let's go with two of them global
national turned 20 in september this was
a neat moment all those years ago
y is for your home canada welcome back
the two michaels in september can you
see me
and finally zed is for zero and it's for
my favorite story of the year it was a
reunion that had a zero percent chance
of happening two women in their 90s who
grew up jewish in nazi germany separated
each thinking the other was dead for 82
years i think i have a whole new family
their first reunion was over zoom with
their families eventually it was in
person
but they now talk all the time
it's always nice to be reminded
friendship yeah yeah good is pretty
powerful
well before we leave you tonight and for
2021 we want to say goodbye to somebody
on our team who's been working
tirelessly is talented and now nearly
retired today global news editor ted
anhorn is wrapping up a career that
spanned more than 40 years he's played a
pivotal role in shaping this show his
quick and very creative work is going to
be missed all the best head from all of
us
and that's global national for this
friday and for this year i'm sonya diol
and as you get ready to welcome 2022
here's how some places in the world have
been celebrating
and we leave you with the fireworks in
dubai at the world's tallest building
the burj khalifa thank you so much for
watching on behalf of dorner and the
entire global national team wishing you
a very very happy new year
you